Thank reason for putting this event
together it took it took a lot of work
and resources and I and I Anna and I
appreciate it very very much and I'm
sure that not just everybody here does
but all of those listening through the
electronic media obviously it would have
been even better I had I been invited as
I should have been to the debate itself
and that is something that illustrates
the bankruptcy of the current two-party
system the the hubris the arrogance if
you will the audacity as Senator Obama
would say of the two parties gaming the
system so that any viewpoint any any any
opportunity to have a different
viewpoint or a different perspective
presented is absolutely unacceptable to
them and I think it would behoove all of
us on behalf of the American people most
of whom actually believe in a more open
robust debate fifty-five percent
according to a recent Zogby poll believe
that that Bob bars libertarian nominee
should have been invited to the debate I
think that it would behoove all of us to
make that view known to not just the
Commission on presidential debate but
the national media as well which are
complicit in in closing off this system
just to the two status quo parties is
there a place where the US should be
fighting al-qaeda in a foreign country
if so where if not why not well we
should we should be fighting anybody who
attacks us whether it's al Qaeda or if
there's another terrorist group out
there if they take action against us and
clearly al Qaeda did on 911 and in other
instances around the world we ought to
go after them I do not believe that it
is at all inappropriate for military
purposes to take action against those
who have or have the capability and are
imminently poised to take action against
us a question from a German journalist
friend
is what should be done from the US
presidents point of view about Iran what
we ought to do is we ought not to be so
so limited in our view so constrained in
our view of both that region of the
world and with regard to Iran that we do
not take advantage of a number of
factors that lend themselves to a very
long-term constructive relationship with
the country and the people of Iran the
people in the country of Iran have a
very strong pro-western view of the
world they have a very free market view
of the world they have a very robust
economy that could of course be much
more robust if the country were opened
up and the market forces allowed to
flourish which under the current
leadership it is very constrained but
given all of that given our prior
history of a very good relationship with
Iran given the the type of country that
it is the economy the political
structure unlike Iraq Iran has a history
of participatory government it is a very
homogenous population very well-educated
population very diverse economy all of
those things lend themselves to a
productive relationship with us and we
ought to be exploring ways to develop
that not constantly look for reasons not
to there are ways that we can approach
it directly through negotiations you
don't all of a sudden jump jump over all
of the intermediary steps and
immediately say oh let's sit down with
with the leader but there are some very
specific intermediary steps that we can
begin we ought to begin we can also
approach this at the same time through
our allies such as Germany for example
that have robust economic and political
diplomatic relations with Iran part of
the problem that I think senator Obama
correctly points out is in many respects
our relations with a number of so many
countries that we're on the
round-the-world have cooled as a result
of the you know these manifestations of
the so-called Bush Doctrine that we no
longer have the capability to use the
good offices of our allied nations to
assist us better develop relations with
other countries including Iran you
mentioned the Bush Doctrine what with a
bob barr doctrine look like the bob barr
doctrine would look very different as a
matter of fact it would have nothing at
all in common with the with the Bush
Doctrine the bar doctor would be a
constitutional doctrine it would truly
put the the emphasis on defense in
national defense policy we would
continue to maintain as we do currently
the best the strong is the most
technologically advanced military on the
face of the earth we we need that we
should continue to employ our our
military to protect our nation our
sovereignty as well as to protect
whatever facilities and personnel we
have stationed around the world insofar
as we never know from day to day where
the next crisis might crop up where the
next attack on us facilities US
personnel might come from it is
important to maintain landing rights
agreements with a whole range of
countries to maintain overflight
agreements with with as many countries
as possible to maintain port facilities
in key areas around the world in all of
the navigable oceans of the world so
that when a problem does crop up we have
the ability to project our force where
necessary and when necessary but but it
does not mean occupying foreign nations
it does not mean preemptively striking
at a foreign nation it means also
relying on good and demanding good sound
foreign intelligence and actually
listening to and acting on that foreign
intelligence that hour that we do have
the capability of developing yet we have
allowed to fall into disrepair through
politicizing our foreign intelligence
apparatus in recent years you're against
the bailout what should the federal
government do about the economic crisis
instead if anything there are a number
of things that the federal government
ought to do one is start prosecuting the
fact that we have by various estimates
hundreds of billions if not trillions of
billion trillions of dollars of bad
paper floating around out there which
has been propped up and allowed to
recirculate time and again through the
US economy by virtue direct as a direct
result of federal policies designed to
artificially push home ownership clearly
indicates to me that there is fraud
involved yet we have not seen any
prosecutions the word is that there are
a number of active investigations in
several US Attorneys offices around the
country but the fact of the matter is
there have been no evert investigations
must let much less prosecutions that
needs to have a much higher priority I
think the what the what we ought to be
doing is looking at creating more
transparency in the laws and regulations
not more regulation not more government
control there are a number of tools that
are available also to the government
such as taking institutions that are
that are failing and placing them into
receivership use of the bankruptcy laws
chapter 7 to liquidate some of these
failed institutions to at least get
something on the dollar in return for
selling off their assets as opposed to
simply pumping a trillion dollars of US
taxpayer money into doing exactly the
same thing that got us into the problem
in the first place and that is buying up
mortgage based securities with no value
you had a very public sort of falling
out or miscommunication with Ron Paul
last week I think it was and he ended up
endorsing chuck baldwin there press
conferences briefly what went wrong and
what would you say to those out there
who were all supporters were
disappointed in your behavior during
that process well what they ought to be
is disappointed in Ron Paul's behavior
endorsing the theocratic candidate that
is
baldwin whose party platform there's
very little relationship to the true
libertarian platform makes no sense
whatsoever what we are trying to do
through my nomination and candidacy as
libertarian nominee is what we would
have hoped ron paul would have done and
that is to provide true focused
leadership for the libertarian movement
instead what what Congressman Paul did a
couple of weeks ago was to hold a news
conference as a sitting Republican
member of Congress who by all accounts
intends to remain a Republican member of
Congress and invite for very divergent
candidates the Constitution candidate
the green party candidate and
independent candidate and the
Libertarian candidate and present those
as sort of a godfather to the American
people and say you have four candidates
here who stand for very very different
messages vote for one of them that's not
leadership that's not moving the
libertarian agenda which Ron Paul used
to a spouse and do so very eloquently
forward